republicans have just won a major
victory at the supreme court over a
controversial new congressional map in
the state of alabama now the voting
rights advocates say the
republican-drawn map dilutes the power
of black voters and violates federal law
but that is not how a majority of the
justices saw it jan crawford is at the
supreme court with more on the story jan
good morning the justices have spoken
they have for now gail i mean the court
is siding with state republicans and
said it was just too close to alabama's
election absentee voting is starting in
just seven weeks to completely redraw
the state's legislative district so that
means the republican drawn map will stay
in place this year with just one black
majority district in a state where black
people make up 27 percent of the
population the five conservative
justices voted to block a lower court
ruling that had ordered the state to
draw a new map just as brett kavanaugh
explained it's one thing for a state on
its own to toy with election laws but
it's quite another thing for a federal
court to swoop in and redo a state
selection laws in the period close to an
election dissenting justice selena kagan
wrote alabama is not entitled to keep
violating black alabamians voting rights
just because the court's order came down
in the first month of an election year
chief justice john roberts and the three
liberal justices would have allowed a
new court-ordered map with two black
majority districts to stand while the
legal challenge continues and with the
court already agreeing to take on an
affirmative action case next year in
university admissions this means two
racially charged issues are certain to
be at the forefront of those
confirmation hearings for the new
justice which president biden has said
will be a black woman
tony
jan thank you very much